[Musique]
dans le nord du Portugal guimaraesh
regorge d'histoire
ancienne capitale du pays laver les sa
région sont aussi l'un des bastions
d'une industrie bien établie
entreprise familiale fondée il y a
environ 30 ans louispex se spécialise
dans la confection de maillots de bain
elle fournit notamment Dior et plusieurs
autres clients européen et américains le
fondateur edwardo Freitas s'attendait à
ce que les impacts de la pandémie se
traduisent par des difficultés sur le
plan financier
ont été fantastiques dit-il en 2022
l'entreprise qui compte 72 employés a
connu son meilleur chiffre d'affaires
avec les problèmes qu'on vécu des
chaînes d'approvisionnement la proximité
des fournisseurs est devenu un facteur
important pour les clients
de cette entreprise qui les affaires
vont bien l'an dernier l'industrie
portugaise du textile à exporter
l'équivalent de plus de 6 milliards
d'euros un record
chérie Opel les machines tournent à
plein régime mais comme tout le secteur
du textile cette compagnie qui compte
plus de 1000 employés à traverser des
périodes plus difficiles
d'amands le patron José Olivera rappelle
qu'il y a quelques dizaines d'années le
Portugal a été affecté par des
délocalisations d'autres pays notamment
en Asie cet homme dont le grand-père a
fondé l'entreprise il y a presque 100
ans explique que Riopel a dû innover
pour se démarquer
une machine équipée de caméra pour mieux
contrôler la qualité de ses produits
comme quoi pour être compétitif le
Portugal ne mise pas uniquement sur ses
coûts de production notamment au niveau
de la main d'oeuvre le salaire minimum y
est deux fois moins élevé qu'en France
puis près de trois ans on a une
recherche importante de clients du
Canada on a des clients comme la maison
ça ment comme purink un temps concession
mais les acheteurs avec lesquels
travaillent Riopel sont surtout français
Cristina Goncalves explique que la
dimension sociale entourant la
production prend de plus en plus de
place dans la réflexion des clients
aujourd'hui les clients recherchent la
traçabilité le respect des auditions de
l'environnement et là aussi on est très
actif là dessus on recherche toujours à
nos actualiser
de son propre parc d'énergie solaire
l'entreprise prévoit d'être carbone
neutre d'ici quelques années
avec son agence anacrouse cernes
intermédiaire entre les usines
portugaises et les clients étrangers
cette experte de l'industrie assure que
les acheteurs sont de plus en plus
conscients des coûts liés à leurs
exigences ils viennent ils disent ah
combien de panneaux solaires tu as tu
vas réussir à
avoir ou 80% ou 100% il faut les mettre
ils veulent que les usines et des bonnes
conditions pour les employés il faut
avoir une usine propre il faut arriver
dans une usine et voir les jeunes qui
travaillent dans la machine avec un
petit peu de sourire mais tout ça se
fait Noël le Portugal avec ses 10
millions d'habitants on a plus de toute
façon pas rivaliser avec des pays qui
produisent de très grandes quantités de
vêtements à bas prix le Portugal doit
comprendre qu'à un certain moment nous
devons être tournés par un marché du
luxe
le respect de l'environnement et les
bonnes conditions de travail font aussi
partie de la recette du succès et
l'entreprise n'échappe pas au défi
auquel sont confrontés tous les acteurs
de l'industrie l'inflation et la
difficulté de recruter de nouveaux
employés
de sa productivité en bonne santé son
secteur et toutefois prêt à affronter
les difficultés avec des bases solides
l'industrie portugaise du textile tient
à bien plus qu'un fil